hello my name is gal i'm here with riyad
and today we'll talk about soda random
self reductions for np complete problems
this is a joint work with robert robery
and a soft shuster
our starting point is random
self-reduction
we say that language l is randomly
self-reducible if designed in membership
in l can be reduced in polynomial time
to deciding membership in l for
uniformly random instances as we can see
here we have x which is a worst case
instance
and we can reduce the membership
the designing membership for x in
polynomial time to descending membership
of y
y1 to yk which are uniformly random
instances
a famous example is the discrete
logarithm problem first let's define
what the discord logarithm is
given a cycle group g and a generator g
the logarithm of x to the base g is an
integer k such that g to the power of k
equals x
and the discrete logarithm problem is
simply to compute the logarithm of x
there is a very simple random
self-reduction for this problem
given an input x
we pick
z uniformly at random from the group and
we set y to be x times g to the power of
z
it's easy to see that y is distributed
uniformly
unifor uniformly at the groove
and we can recover the logarithm of x
from the logarithm of y
another example is computing the
permanent of a matrix and it's important
to see that both of these examples are
not are assumed not to be np complete
so it is a natural question whether
there is an np-complete problem which
has random self-reduction
and
finding them in fourth row proved that
unless the polynomial hierarchy
collapses at the third level
the answer is negative there is no
non-adaptive random self-reduction for
np complete problems where non-adaptive
means that future queries cannot depend
on earlier queries
from the reduction the idea of the proof
is that given
some language l in np
that has non-adaptive random
self-reduction we can construct an am
poly protocol for the complement of l
and
from this it follows that if such a
language existed then the polynomial
hierarchy would have been collapsed on
the third at third level
and these results were later improved by
bogdanov and trevison
one way to relax the requirement of
funding self-reduction
is to require the queries of the
reduction to be pseudorandom instead of
random with respect to some complexity
class c
we say that the sequence of
distributions d is epsilon and
pseudorandom with respect to c
it's a classical definition if for all
distinguisher in c
the distinguishing distinction adventure
that adventured is smaller than epsilon
and similarly a pseudorandom
self-reduction
is a reduction where
the queries are
pseudorandom
which means that they are
indistinguishable from the uniform
distribution
and
hirihara and santaman showed the
pseudorandom self-reduction for the mcsp
problem
now there are many good reasons to
believe that the mcsp problem is not np
complete
and they
suggested
that this fact
shows further this further separation of
mcsp from
np completeness
uh and the reduction works as follows so
there's an input x which is a truth
table of some function
and we simply xor it with the output of
this exponentially secure so the random
generator
now the output of this reduction is
pseudorandom by definition right if you
assume that um g of r is a the output of
x exponentially secures to the random
generator then why the result of this
reduction is going to be pseudorandom
and the result of this reduction
of this
xor process
the size of the circuit that computes
the truth table of the result is roughly
the same as the circuit size for x
and essentially this is why the
reduction
works we have so mcsp is a minimization
problem
where there exists so they run
distribution d
on inputs with small values right
assuming the existence of exponentially
secure prg
and x are in the input x with
value from d roughly keeps the value of
x and
overall this is why
we found that the reduction works
and we try to take these principles and
try to apply them on some np complete
language
and this is we managed to do it and
the first result that we show in this
paper is that the max clique problem
emits a non-adaptive pseudorandom
self-reduction
assuming the non-uniform planted click
conjecture
and we also showed that more generally
for every non-trivial hereditary
property pi
the problem of finding the
largest subgraph in the property
also it meets pseudorandom
self-reduction um under the same
hardness assumption under the
non-uniform planted clip
so what the conjecture so what is the
conjecture um first we have
g
and half which is the uniform
distribution of our graphs within
vertices
and we have the planted click
distribution we just take a random graph
and plant the clique of size n to the
power of xylem in it
the conjecture is that
there is no polynomial size sequence of
circuits that can distinguish between a
random graph and around the graph with
the planted clique
with advantage of one over n to the tau
for some tau between zero and one
and now riyadh will explain to you about
the reduction
hi i'm riyadh i will be showing the
reduction
and so
can i go to the next store please
and the reduction is given a graph g
within vertices it does the following
first it chooses a state s outside into
the power of epsilon where epsilon is
less than epsilon zero from from the
from the conjecture
it fixes the set s
and it fixes all the edges in s
and randomizes all other edges so every
edge here and on the output if it's in a
in s it will
stay depending whether it existed in the
original graph and
it would be random with probability half
if the if the one edge is the
if one side of the edge is outside of
this
and so some properties of of the
of this reduction first if the graph
tree has a click of size k
then f of g has a click of side k
divided by two times n to the power of
minus one minus epsilon high probability
the reason is that on average
uh
the click size will be at least k
divided by the n to the power of minus
epsilon because
a click of size k and the random set of
size into the power of epsilon will have
an intersection of size k divided by n
power 1 and x epsilon
and the type of query it will be at
least half of that
and the second priority is that the
click size will not increase by a lot
and if f of g
uh the click size for g is not larger
than macro size of g plus three log n
with high probability
and the reason is that the
click size of f of g is bounded by the
fixed size of s and the clear side of
the complement of this
when s it's at most the electric side of
the original graph
and on the is that it's at most the
real game with high probability on
average it's tool again and with high
probability
it's better than three million
total it's the original
click size plus figure
and the third property is pseudonymous
which we will show now
and this time
assume that for some
input graph g adversary for distinguish
between the distribution of f of three
and a
uniformly random graph r
and
then
consider the graph f of g
solar tree or k where k is the complete
graph
now first f of jigsaw g has an
independent set in s and everything else
is random by the the way we defined f
so if we take it for g solving 4k it
would have a click with in s
it's with slides in the power of epsilon
and everything else is random so this is
a graph with a click of side enter power
epsilon
and the graph arcs or gx or k is just a
random graph because r is random and g
and they are constant
and some total adversary will be able to
distinguish between
a graph
that is uniformly random and a graph
with a planetary equal size input power
epsilon
contradicting the planetary conjunction
this a similar trick was used in the
mcsp case the
pretty much the same sources
so we have to the randomness so in total
what we have is
absolute random self-reduction that
approximates click up to a factor of n
to the power of one minus epsilon
which is known to be np-half so there is
a reduction from
a click to the approximation of click
and we can compose the introduction that
get overall
a random self-reduction absolute random
self-reduction from click to itself
now why did this reduction work which
property is completely completely used
first of all
that is smaller random inputs
it is approximately two log n on a
random input this with the with the
property of localness or stability
means that uh
fixing a small
subset of name but was enough to keep
to keep
to not change the output too much
and because it's very hard to
approximate
uh
this
relatively large change of input power
finance epsilon was enough to
uh to show a random self-reduction it
was still and
now for general heritage properties
uh that's pretty much the same reduction
works
and the reason is that
for any infinite non-derivative property
by
uh
the problem of finding the maximum sub
graph still satisfies the three
properties
it is still smaller random inputs
and it's also
np hard to approximate with the same
factor of inter power from as epsilon
so the exact same proof works for for
the general case as well
okay
um
foreign